Hey, how's going bros!
My name is Peeeeewdiepie!
We're back with another episode of The Last Guardian!
Hey, how you doing there Trico?
*silent*
Excellent, let's keep going
I'm really exited, because..we haven't actually seen anything beyond this point
I love how the light....flashes...look at my...outline....my stroke.. looks awesome
Okay..well
I think I've praised this game enough already
Let'sss just..keep going
You know, this would be a lot easier if I had shoes
Trico you can't wear shoes cause you're a CHICKEN
Look at that, he just puts his hand there, it's so cool
WHAT ARE YOU LOOKIN' AT ME FOR?
"Do you have anymore shnacks?"
No I don't
K let's go look for it Jesus Christ
I have no idea what's gonna happen now cause like..
I played the demo part before and..that's jus-
..well what we played in the last episode
So I don't know..
...what's about to come
OOAAAAAAHHH NO FUCK
Alright, I'm out
Fuck this
Trico
Healp
Why you so slow anyway Jesus
Eh—OH he's scared of the eye, fuck—okay...
Are they coming here?
Ah, they're shooting me!
Fuck!
Okay.
We're just gonna have to be fast.
No?
We can shake those off!
WOAAHH LOOK AT THAT!!!
Ahh—no—shake it off, shake it off.
Shake it off x3
Fuck.
Alright, so what do I do here? Fuck.
*skip*
Here we go...
Don't grab me!
Run, run, run...
WOOW!
Alright, now what?
Trico!
Oh, he doesn't want to help me 'cause he's scared!
Ok, lets run around here,
lets trick them down.
Oh, here we go!
Up, up, up, up, up!
Up!
Whatever your name is!
AHH!
That was a genuine scream like a girl!
Jesus!
Ok here we go, now lets grip the bell!
Eh
eh!
Geh!
What does this do!?
I don't know what it does!
Oh my god!
This was not part of the plan I swear to God,
Jesus Christ!
Come on, need a little further there we go,
jump up!
WOOW!
We got this!
Easy!
Now you goin' down!
To fucker town!
Goodbye! Goodbye!
I'm going to leave the bridge now!
There you go!
NOW FUCK 'EM UP TRICO!
THAT'S MA BOY!
YEAH!
YOU FUCK WITH ME, YOU FUCK WITH HIM!
That's right!
Fuck yeah Trico!
Eat them! x2
I'm fuckin' ea- OH NO, you jumped too far!
Ok, there we go!
Hey!
Fuck 'em up!
Now we gotta calm him down!
That's ok Trico, that's ok!
That's ok.
They're all dead.
You murdered them all, ok, no,
calm down.
Trico
Buddy
There you go!
Alright, h-he keeps eating it!
I'm pretty sure they're all dead Trico!
See that was fun!
Ok, I know you were giving me a tip there...
But I feel like you were just being condescending!
Oh he is still so crazy!
He doesn't wann- the controls are fucking wonky sometimes!
There we go,
thank you.
It's almost as if doing this very specific thing,
it might do something else!
Wink, wink, wink...
Thanks game, 'ppreciate y-
appreciate that!
You told me twice already!
Jesus Christ!
'aite Trico,
where do you think we should go?
So I've learned, from you bro's comments, that...
That if he's looking somewhere and grunting, that means he wants to go there.
See he's looking there now..
Which means i have to jump on top of him.
if his eyes are white, it means.. he is intre-
OH GOD!
Alright! See he went for it!
And if he's red, he's scared.
Which is obvious..
Oh ok, we go here!
Thanks Trico!
You da best
"i know"
OW!
That's gotta hurt my feet..
Oh cool we can walk here!
Dude this is so cool!
The framerate is like 6...
What the fuck, playstation!
Okay, oh, well there we go!
look at that...
I just want to breathe it all in,
it's so pr--
SHUT UP TRICO!
I'm coming!
We've been through this...
Alright did a 'lil jump there for no reason.
What happens if we grab this?
Nothing..
Ok, well this seems like a really fun rollercoaster,
if you wanna die...
ya know?
Oh God, I shouldn't have done that.
He can't come?
Okay, there's Heisenberg here, because there are butterflies.
That means there's drugs around...
That's his favorite thing
Ok, come on.
Walk it off
walk it off buddy.
Jus- there you go, there you go.
Alright, we got- ahh
Stupid, of course, we gotta open for him!
You didn't think i forgot about ya!
Did ya?
"Oh my God!"
"You came back for me,
as you always do!"
"I am in your debt"
shut up
now
Where do we go?
We go out here?
He's gonna be scared of the eye,
so we gotta get rid of that shit.
He doesn't like "Jack Septiceye",
ya know, I can't blame him...
Oh my god, ok, this is a lil more complicated
than i thought..
Ok we gotta chain,
oh my god...
What the fuck did you just do?
Jesus
"I don't like it, I don't like it, get it away from me,
disgusting!"
ok well..
Wow, way to be patronizing dude.
'aite, how do we get rid of that?
I don't know how to get rid of it
ok? I don't know!
It's complicated!
Look at this place though, it's amazing!
Who built these and why?
They don't make fuck all shh- sence.
Alright, he's scared, he's scared
"APPABACHIE"
Appabachie please
Jesus, I'm working on it!
There you go, you're welco- oh my god.
You got snacks!
Dude we got so much snacking!
"Oh my god" x2,
"Give it to me" x2
"Please, I've been a really good boy!"
"I've been such a good boy!"
Here you go buddy
OH! Gottem!
Nice!
Another one!
Why not? I spoil you today,
you've been good!
You've been a good dog.
"What! I'm not a dog!
I'm a cat, dog, fish, chicken!"
"How dare you!"
Ok, where we go!
3..
2...
1...
Catch it!
[ Laughs ]
Aww, he's sad now...
it's over.
"God dammit!"
"that was smooth shit"
Alright, we goin' this way
Jesus Christ, dude!
Aww, i love the brightness..
this is so crazy!
But here's m--
no...
Some epic parkouring going on right here
So this is such a huge society
but why are there no...
people...
Maybe we transported in from the future
Alright, i don't want to fail now!
Yeah!
that's it boy!
Alright, I think I'm goin' this way..
Nailed it.
Alright! Feels good in my butt!
Now lets drop down gently..
Excellent!
Alright now..
Oh we gotta do one of those swinging things..
Right, it's gonna go down..
that's it..
that's it, lil bit more..
then we go back..
Swinging mergigger thing
then as high as possible
high as possible
high as- ok here we go!
OH my God!
Jesus Christ!
I was hoping for you to fall!
shut up!
got dammit!
So rude!
so rude.
I'm trynna help you here, ya know?
"Kill it, kill it, kill it!"
Alright what do I do now?
Oh my god, i don't know..
how do i?
Seriously I didn't have a plan B on this,
ya know?
Can I go up here?
I can! ok
Well it hurt my fingers..
Well you know what, I wouldn't do this in real life...
My hands are so sweaty right now, I can't even.
begin to describe.. how they feel..
Am I supposed to climb this actual thing?
Oh my God...
no..
No...
I don't feel good doing this..
ok.
I take no pleasure in this.
ok..
[ Screams In PewDiePie ]
did that on purpose.
Don't fall again, you loser!
shut up!
okay?
I died for you..
you should be happy!
I can't really see where I'm supposed to go.. I guess I'm supposed to go up on it..
Not fuckin'
There's a hole in the glass, I didn't realize!
And he just went right through.
Fuck me... that's why I fell off, it's because you're supposed to do this.
Oh my god, that is so fucking cool though, I'm glad they made me do this!
No!
That's a lie!
"Whoa!
What the hell is that!?"
That's where we need to go buddy!
GRAB to something,
Jesus Christ!
Ok, are we stuck now? No we're not.
Okay.
Okay, alright, we need to get higher.
There's nowhere to go really...
We need to go down here
Heights man.
I don't have a general problem with heights...
It's just...
I just think this would make anyone feel uncomfortable, I really do..
Oh no, don't make me go through again...
That's a cool puzzle..
but i don't like it...
No, I don't like it..
No..
oh God, ok, alright
fuck,
I don't know..
There we go...
and then we just do this.
Are you with me?
I need your support.
Are you shitting yourself as much as I am?
I don't think that's possible...
Alright lets wait for it...
wait for it..
GO!
now what?
Now what's the genius plan her--
"that's the second time, ya bitch"
Why you sassin' me?
Why are you sassin' me?
Right, lets wait for it to dangle..
That's what she sa- shut up.
Okay.
Why's it not dangling?
Don't need to dangle x2
I just want him to grab this chain, so he can climb up it right...
He doesn't fuckin' do it..
it prolly means we're not supposed to do that...
"oh pewds this is obvious, it's painful to watch at this point!"
Oh, okay, I'm sure whenever you play games it's all perfect...
I'm trying here, alright?
I need support.
I need help.
Alright.
Last try.
If I don't fai-
if I don't do this..
I will quit this lets play, right now.
See nailed it. Not a problem.
Okay.
It's been fun, thank you guys for watching, leave a like if you enjoyed, and I'll see you bros... In the next episode
Stay awesome!
Okay well maybe not..
maybe not..
Maybe I will finish it..
What's that?
Danny Devito, really wants me to finish and he's supporting me... unlike you are right now, okay?
Nah, I'm kidding, I appreciate it.
Alright. Here we go.
Here we go. This is easy...
this is easy..
Easy peasy, lemon pateasy.
That's it, that's... pateasy.
How do I get rid of this fuckin' thing?
Oh..
Okay, you hold circle to climb chains...
my fucking bad, I'm an idiot.
Alright, here we go.
Whoa, Okay, we got something going...
Circle!
There! Okay, fuck I'm stupid!
How could I not know that at this point?
This is fucking... oh my god...
DON'T FALL!
Even my feet are sweaty at this point.
I don't think anyone cares..
Who put this up here!?
It's like a tram system goin' on,
with all the cables...
the hell..
Oh shit we did it. We did it!
Thank you!
Thank you Danny Devito, you will not be necessary any further, thank you for your servi--
Jesus Christ, you almost killed me, you fuckin'...
Devito...
Here we go...
Now all we gotta do is grip this!
Then we gotta...
ahh..
Ah of course, all i really had to do was...
alright..
There it is, now he's goin'
We are goin', to the- bahhh.. this is going to be counter weighted!
We're fine!
How do I get down?
For real, how do I get down?
JUST WAIT THERE ,I'LL BE RIGHT THERE!
I'm sure Trico's going to do something...
Oh my god, dude you broke the whole thing!
Hey if I jump will you catch me?
"yeah, yeah, yeah, don't worry 'bout it, i gotcha"
HELL YEAH TRICO!
That was fuckin' awesome! Now I'm gonna hol-
Good job buddy, good job...
Now lets go!
Lets go to Narnia!
Here we go, there we go, alright I finally understand,
Jesus Chri- woops
"watch this, watch this, light as a feather!"
"watch this"
I'm so skinny now..
That's it, look at that!
So easy!
Lets do anot- oh my god, that's high, alright, he can do it...
"Oh my god, no that's another mirror,
fuck that, fuck that!"
Dude I got you, don't worry about it, okay?
"i don't like it, x2
it's ugly, x2"
"get it away from me!"
Can we just take a moment and appreciate all of this?
Ok, well, we did it...
Lets push this thing, off the ground..
Bye, bye!
Nailed it!
Alright, I'm back I had a lil break, but for you it was INSTANT!
How does that work!?
Forgot how pretty this game is, every time I leave it...
Hey, ya lil puss... I got it done man!
I got it does for you!
Pick up!
Oh you want a pot?
Maybe I need to get out of the way, so he can jump off of that.
It's gonna break, I'm too fat!
He doesn't wanna come?
There you go, now he's coming!
WHOA! NO! NO !NO!
Dude you are fat!
Oh I gotta get up on you!
I swear I hit up!
Nailed it!
Right...
I missed this epic opportunity, what the fuck...
I keep dying now..
'aite, I'm gonna have to jump up on you real fast!
Lets go buddy!
Run like the wind!
Oh my god, I dunno if i'm still on it, I have no idea.
JUMP TRICO!
Where am I?
I fell off!
[ Laughs In Swedish ]
Oh my god..
That's embarrassing...
Run!
Igotta get- AHSHIT! I'm in a really bad spot here...
I'm still on him! I'm still on you Trico!
Keep goin!
I'm holding on everything I got!
Come on!
oh my god..
lets never do that again...
uh... no..
no, you're too fat!
"I'm not too fat, i swear I can do it!"
We're kinda stuck aren't we?
What's your plan here? What's the.. oh shit..
Can you not do that?
I'm fucking dying..
Lets just try and jump..
You know what, fuck it..
Do it, do it, he's doing it!
There's no way he can do it, it's too far!
Hey, calm down!
I'm gonna get that bridge down for ya!
Epic. Jump.
It's either here..
I'm just gonna have to hope that this works out..
I hope you brought a snack Trico!
'Cause I might be a while!
"you fuckin' asshole!
You better come back here boy!"
"I saved your life!"
Lets get that draw bridge open, A.S.A.P!
Why there is a draw bridge in the fucking sky, is beyond me.. but I didn't make this fucking universe, okay?
Did my controller die? No, he just doesn't want to move...
Look at the animation it's so cool
What kind of game have you seen anyone do this?
It's still wonky.. but when it works it's beautiful.
Oh shit, alright, i just went for it!
Hopefully there's no trolls here. I hate them, i hate them so much.
Oh well.. there you go..
Well I don't know, there's really no away around this guy...
So much for sneaking, huh?
Trico's prolly freakin' out right now!
You know, when my big brother comes later, he's goin' kick yo ass!
Shit x4
I could've just ran past him
Where does he wanna take me anyway!
Am I the only one getting sexual undertones?
Here's where we jump- don't fuckin' touch me!
There it is
Asshole!
Don't need you...
Alright lets go down
I think he's coming for me..
Ah for fuck sakes man!
My god! it is fucking annoying when you do that!
You fucking bitch!
Now I know the Germans, what they di---
You're so annoying!
Can you just not be an asshole?
Have you tried that?
Can you climb these things a lil slower, that would be great, thank you!
I'm just, one floor down right now, I think that's all that happened
Or am I on the same floor?
Did I just fuckin' walk in circles!
There's a lever here!
Hurry!
Oh, wow, what a genius...
DUDE THERE'SA BAT THERE!
What is the bat doin', is that a pterodactyl!?
Salamanders are now bats!
that is cool!
ok, great!
alright, great. oh god, there's more!
I'm just gonna run for it, that's my battle plan right now!
But you gotta be careful where yo- fucking deadend...
IF YOU GUYS TOUCH TRICO, I SWEAR TO GOD I WILL TELL YOUR MUM!
Gotem!
They better not be hurting Trico, i'm gonna be super duper pissed..
I think in here's another lever...
Open another gate, it's probably on top as well.
This is getting really intense!
Getting really exciting!
So he's prolly walked up already
There's another one...
ANOTHER one!
That's right, that's right, FUCK!
Stop!
God damn, they are so creepy!
Oh my god x2
Jesus Christ, i'm alive!
Hang in there Trico!
I gotcha buddy!
I got you!
Now! Actually I have no idea what to do.
Hurry up, x4
Oh shit, i'm up--- okay, not that one...
Carefull, x3
This has to be the most intense climbing i've done in a video game, and i've played uncharted!
I suppose I will not go on that one
Oh no they're hurting Trico! No!
No!
Come on man!
I'm just going to jump, what else can I do?
Your friend is in pain!
No Trico, no!
No!
TRICO NO!
NO!
TRICO!
WHAT DO I DO!?
I will remove the spears I swear, but I think the real problem is --- "help me pewds!"
I'm in, I'm in
Where's the lever!? x2
Hang on tight buddy, i'm almost there!
There it is!
Come on Trico!
"dude that fuckin hurt!"
Poor soul...
hey buddy, thanks for doin' that
That was cool, I didn't expect him to do that.
I swear i have no idea how that got there!
When will they stop throwing spears at you?
Okay we got a new area!
Pile of shit
You know what? Someone deserves some drugs.. I will find some for you, okay? You did good buddy.
There's butterflies, which usually means there's drugs..
*applies to real-life as well*
I don't know where though..
Are you too fat again?
I feel like we haven't progressed anything.
It's not like journey, where you know you have a goal to work towards or whatever...
I wonder if there are secret areas you can climb too and shit... that'd be cool...
Definitely not pull, now lets try push... nope, i got nothing. Trico what about you?
Well listen, I haven't eaten either...
So cute x2
I don't have a snack... i'll find one!
I guess he doesn't want to go with me until we get some snacks.
Quick drive through maybe?
I'll have a number 9, a number 9 large, a number 6 with extra dip, a number 9 with extr-
Yeah, dead memes, you're welcome everyone...
Oh boy, we better ride this thing don't we.
You're not gonna move huh?
that's great...
Well i'm glad i solved that for everyone
Lets find some fuckin' food then, Jesus Christ mate!
There we go!
That's all we need!
This place is creepy
but very cool
TRICO I FOUND DRUGS!
How do I get 'em out?
I don't think I can... I mean how could I possibly..
Don't go anywhere... Jesus!
There you go, look at that, look, at THAT!
did it
That wasn't too bad, that probably saves us some time...
Hey Trico!
You hungry buddy!?
Papa gotta snack!
"Oh my God" x2
"O M G"
"O M F G"
"what the!? NO! NO! You got my favorite!"
"a number 9! you gotta number 9!
I'm fuckin' starving... did you bring the extra dip?"
here you go buddy
"That felt so good"
"imma chicken-bird, salamon, dogfish"
Alright! I'm back in action!
Hey look there's more bats!
I'm gonna do all this work... without any food complaints... and just keep goin'
do I ask for some...
Do I ask for some butterfly drugs... No I Do Not!
Do I do all this shit anyway? Yes I do. How can I pull this gate open when i'm just this tiny little boy?
It doesn't matter...
We did it Trico
Be careful though
You're not being very careful
that's fine
Oh Mama! You fucking went for it!
I did not expect that x2
Where are we now?
Is this... supposed to be another draw bridge?
I'm gonna jump up on ya
gotta good feelin about this one Trico..
gotta great feelin about this
Lets do it buddy!
There's an eye out there
Push through buddy
What am I looking at? no one knows...
oh he sees the eye now
Ok, well that was ruined by camera angles.. so great..
he doesn't want to go further
Guess this is one of those thing where I have to do everything, huh?
You know what fine, alright, fine. I'M SCARED OKAY!
WHAT ARE YOU DOIN? WHAT IS THAT?
Oh he is actually jumping...
Oh my god
You never know with Trico, he seems to do what the fuck he wants..
It's so amazing because it makes you really feel the depth of the height...
and it makes it so much cooler when you are behind him.
oh.. yeah that's a problem
Can you explain at least why you don't like them so i can-- there's a rope here.
Time for Papa Pewds to take care of business!
and... i went through it..
Well i was tele-transported, through time and space... to this thing...
great
that's what i wanted
This time, lets just walk down on it... i know that seems crazy...
what the fuck did you do now Trico?
i heard you do something!
here we go
that's it, this is cool
this is VERY cool
I don't think
Awh man..
how are yo--
Look at the detail on the background it's so fucking amazing.
I'm glad this game came out on the P- ok you just need to-- on the PS4 instead of the PS3..
Oh I remember these green ass-- oh that's a new move, that's a break your arm move..
almost there Trico
Don't you worry bout a thing
Ma little Tricky-Tricky!
Ma Trico Trico, Tricky!
that doesn't work.. great...
oh there's another rope.. okay
Stay there Tri- ok... he doesn't seem to care.
"i don't like it... i don't like it at all"
clearly that's not built for you
great... great... this is just what i wanted.
alright, we're fine.
did that scare you Trico?
"what did something just happen?
'cause i don't even care!"
"feels like imma king"
Jesus Christ
glad we worked this out buddy
more climbing, how 'bout that?
People talk about the story that's amazing in this game, but there really is no much that story so far..
It's more like interpreting yourself.
what is happening?
which i'm totally fine with
look at all those triangles.. beautiful.
who doesn't love a good triangle?
Here we go, hopefully this one doesn't break!
That's a long walk
that's a long, long, long walk.
"i am lookin up your skirt... you have very tiny balls"
alright.. he's getting ready
that does not look stable
do not do that again Trico
he doesn't care.. great
Lucky these come with a mechanism
This game would be a lot easier if you weren't scared of mirrors Trico!
don't jump down!
don't jump down
there ya go
oh my god, counter weight!
didn't think about that, did I.
what's the fastest way down?
Prolly this way
"nailed it!
that was easy... haha!"
oh god!
Catch me!
Thanks for catching me!
Great well glad we did that.
now what?
guess I go up on you
that's it... there we go
he's goin' up there
oh my god
oh okay, i think i'm supposed to climb up here.
maybe not.. maybe you can do it... cool!
actually i could jump up here..
thank you Trico...
FOR NOTHING!
"don't forget about me poods... i love you"
I don't know how i'm supposed to help him get across
I'm just doing this for the
there's a hole here
When there's a hole, there's a way!
wish I was taught
literally just had to wait for him to jump up.
oh my god
we're almost at the top.. come on!
now here's where i should've jumped up... there's another fuckin eye!
last one
not a problem Trico
I know just the Trick-O
I'm tired... okay.. lets just do this last one
this is stupid
Can i squeeze through?
hell yeah.. im not fat like Trico
Trico
Yeah!
I'm not fat like Trico
is that it?
that's it.. okay that should be...
easy buddy!
put your blind fold on buddy
push that shit
oh fuck... i didn't think about this.
I'm fine. x2
Just hangin around Trico
i'm fine... dont worry about it... don't save me
"whatever i'm going to get some tea"
oh he's down there!
"come on ya pussy! do it!"
"do it! I'll catch you!"
WHAT!?
What the fuck?!
Okay, i gotta end that episode there. I think he's supposed to catch you!
Leave a like if you enjoyed this episode, I had fun playing it for you!
And as always...
Stay Awesome bros...